are you looking to pick up the resident  evil 7 collector's edition well now we  know what's in it I'm Tony and this is  your creepy gamespot news update the  highlight of the package is an 8 inch  tall music box made to look like the  Baker's mansion it plays the games theme  song and even lights up in time with the  music the collector's edition also  includes a 4 gigabyte USB Drive made to  look like the infamous dummy finger  you'll get a VHS tape box to carry the  USB drive in plus a lithograph of the  Baker family and a creepy note from them  the whole package will cost you 180  bucks hopefully that doesn't make your  wallet too scared resident evil 7 comes  to ps4 xbox one and pc on january twenty  four twenty seventeen this is the first  time a mainline Resident Evil game has  been created with a first-person view  and you'll be able to play the whole  thing in VR if you dare for all the  latest on Resident Evil you're already  in the right place  you